ray Ratto the Bay Area sports are one of
the great sports writers in America and
he joins us now the most recent article
he wrote for Deadspin the weirder the
finals get the better
how much more weird can it get ray well
I think maybe if they figured out a way
to get LeBron James out of retirement no
I think the perfect thing about this
series is that nobody has any idea who's
got the upper hand yet and that's
through three games I don't remember the
last time a series played out like that
because I mean you talked about the
lawyers having two injured players
they've got three because come on Looney
was important to them well I'm talking
about stars oh okay stars I get but in
terms of them functioning Looney is as
important as anybody who isn't a
megastar because you saw how easy it was
last night for Toronto to deal with
DeMarcus Cousins
they basically length him off the floor
so in that way you know Looney shouldn't
be ignored because the Warriors aren't
very deep so every every competent
player who can hold their own in this
series is important I mean you saw curry
B as curry as curry can be but you also
saw draymond Green failed to be two
players at once and everybody else was
either at their norm or below it I mean
that game truly was never in doubt and
that you know you could say that part of
that is Thompson but nobody else
elevated their game beyond sort of here
their normal levels that the right thing
happened for and and at the right margin
- what do you make of clay strategy I
didn't think he was gonna play last
night because if you aggravate that then
you may lose him the entire series and I
think that Steve Kerr was basically
saying I'll take a bullet and maybe we
lose last night I just got to have him
around because I think this series may
go seven game
well I think part of it was strategic
but part of it was that the Warriors are
a relatively conservative Bunch when it
comes to injuries they gave Chelsea Lane
a lot of leeway when she was there and
they've given the same amount of leeway
to Richburg celebre knee who's the head
of their their medical team now and when
I saw the story that that won't put out
that that the Warriors were reluctant to
play Thompson but Thompson was going to
keep lobbying I thought well that's a
few that's a futile attempt by Thompson
he doesn't win that the Warriors always
give their medical people I think more
leeway to make decisions like that than
most teams too so when I heard that you
know there met their medicals were
reluctant to let him play I said well
then he's not playing well it's a little
different though going into Friday
though I get the feeling Thompson's
playing and I guess the biggest question
mark though Rey is is Kevin Durant
anywhere near game ready and if he is
I'm assuming a minutes count will
probably be put in place for Durant um I
don't know if they'll put a minutes
count on either one of them I think
they'll just go by feel which isn't
normally the way they do this
I think Durant has wanted to play for
about the last week but again he knows
that he's up against a medical people
who are very again very conservative
about when they greenlight people
Thompson you know I don't know if he'll
play Friday because I don't know how
much healing you can do with a hamstring
over two days I think that's why all the
people are assuming they'll both be back
for Game four are a jumping the gun
based on their long years of knowing
nothing about medicine and to assuming
that all of a sudden the philosophy that
the Warriors have always had about
injuries is all of a sudden going to
change just because they need game for
yeah it's a great part yeah I think
I think Steve Kerr might be you know
chewing the furniture a bit about it but
ultimately he's always deferred to the
medical people and if they don't like
what they see today I could easily see
them saying and I plan tomorrow either
McLovin give ray the pull question if
you had a better week's pay who do you
have in the series now the Raptors or
warriors well I'm clinically
underemployed so I've got nothing you
don't have a page dr. Luke if you had a
paycheck to lose ray okay
I'd say Golden State because I think you
know if Durant's playing it's because
he's close to a hundred percent and the
same for Thompson and that just changes
everything Toronto can do I mean last
night they had so much freedom of action
that they could actually shorten their
bench and be better I mean they they
basically you know did that they
dominated Golden State with seven guys
and they all played really well I think
that changes if Durant is let's say 90
percent and if Thompson plays we'll say
he's 90 percent - and all of a sudden
now that's two guys they have to guard
differently than they did in Game three
Game three and I think the Warriors have
the edge now if they lose Friday night
then I think the series is over okay I
do I do like what you brought up and
people just assume that the Warriors
just lost well then Durant and Thompson
have to play that doesn't make them
healthier like all of a sudden you don't
go i Kevin's feeling better because we
lost this last game and I think that
they're they have been very conservative
also it's a little tricky with Kevin
Durant and free agency I'm guessing how
they show their love and care for him or
am i overstating that in a situation
like this right I think you're
overstating it because
I think they would be as solicitous if
they had him under contract for more
years he look if he had his way he too
played last night he did jump he hopped
on one leg but he had done it and I
think the same is true of Thompson but
the days of you know shoot him up and
trot him out there and if they fall down
and die then they fall down and die
those days are pretty much over and it's
also there are their muscles they're not
like this is not bone you know these are
not bone issues these are not you know
tendon issues you can't just shoot up a
muscle because if they go out with a nut
half numbed leg and they do any more
damage they don't know that they're
doing the damage and then you've
shredded you may have shredded a guy's
career so I think the Warriors quite
frankly I don't know that Steve Kerr
wouldn't want that on his conscience
above and beyond everything else and the
medicals like I said they wouldn't want
that either because forevermore even if
you just wanted to be cynical about it
forevermore they'd be known as the
people who ruined Kevin Durant and klay
Thompson III think they're they're being
careful because they're trained to be
careful and they gain nothing by not
being careful if it was a different kind
of injury maybe they treat it
differently but I think given what these
are I think they're basically
approaching this as though they have
season ahead of them and if it means
they don't get a parade then they don't
get a parade I was surprised that there
was no box in one last night on curry
you know that he he put up 47 but I kept
wondering are they gonna use the box in
one why don't you think Toronto did it
because I think nurse knew that five
minutes of practice and a warrior
facility was going to allow Steve Kerr
to show them how to beat the box in one
was great only because it's a surprise
you know and there was no reason to do a
triangle and two because which would be
the two I know I think I think he popped
that out as a one-time thing just on the
spur of the moment but he knew that it's
not hard to
and frankly he didn't have to do
anything it quotes Janki with his
defense based on the fact that the
Warriors had no more offense to provide
I mean I talked about cousins being
inert but you know you know Green was
you know Green did what he could but he
wasn't you know he wasn't by any means
an offensive threat and you know it
would always it would Allah livingstone
you know hasn't played twenty minutes
except one time all year Cooke and Bogut
becoming just all the disguise they are
who they are and there just isn't any
compelling reason why people should have
expected them all to rise up and exceed
their normal limits
all in unison against a really really
good defensive team is it better for the
media if the Warriors win or lose this
finals yeah the media can go to hell I
don't know what it is because you know
what that everybody's gearing up for
free agency anyway yes I mean this is
this is actually the third preseason of
the NBA
there's the preseason there's the
regular season which is a preseason of
its own and now there is this which is
closer to an actual season but not so
much because what we really are
interested in more than anything else is
the sound and smell of burning money
it's the thing we like more than
anything else and it only happens in
basketball because basketball is the
only sport in which players have such an
overwhelming sense of power about their
own futures it doesn't happen in
football or baseball or or hockey or
anything else it's it's in basketball
where players have an inordinate amount
of power to determine their futures and
that's what we love I mean I've been
convinced of it now we've been talking
about where Kevin Durant is going to go
for a year and a half I mean that's a
sign that we've decided to redefine
Christmas
the moment where you had Lauer go into
the stands with that fan is this an NBA
issue or is this a Golden State Warriors
issue with that fan it's a one it's a
Fayette issue because the guys are [ __ ]
and every place has morons I could
easily have seen this being the same
thing if curry had gone into the stands
in Toronto if he goes into the stands
with the wrong guy the wrong guys gonna
decide hey here's my chance
famous for eight seconds before the cops
dragged me off so I don't think it's an
it's an issue for anything except that
you know Lowry goes into the stands and
if you sit that close I mean that's sort
of a risk you run and if you want to do
something else about it that's about you
because I think for the most part
Golden State fans in Toronto's fans are
the same fans they came to see the game
and getting into a fight with Kyle Lowry
is really not anybody getting what their
money's worth is I think it I think
that's a complete one-off and you know
and the time is come and gone ray good
luck keep sending out those resumes and
hopefully you get a job next time I talk
to you that's rough ray righto the
longtime Bay Area sports writer
columnist and his most recent column on
Deadspin the weirder the finals get the
better for more Dan Patrick show tune in
the audience channel 239 on DirecTV
stream for free on BR live or download
the Dan Patrick show at
[Music]